[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
jouer
on vous prenez en tant que membre du
célèbre groupe arcade fire
mais là vous vous lancez dans un album
sur le territoire
pourquoi l'album sont pour moi un
musique ses nouveaux seins
entre temps et il ya beaucoup de types
de musique beaucoup d influence musicale
que frau que je extrêmement élevé
c'est quelque chose qu'on en crée des
compositions c'est quelque chose toutes
les collaborations que j'avais fait
quelque chose mais j'ai besoin une place
par toutes les musiques que j'ai fait et
quoi vivre dans ces mots nouveaux et
c'est une petite billie jean de musique
c'est super important pour moi et il
n'existe pas dans les autres façons
[Musique]
c'est un album construit pourquoi
revenir à cette formule là au lieu de
faire des études pour la radio c'est
vraiment un album et c'est un album en
deux parties d'être un album en deux
parties c'est important c'est pas juste
des chansons des cinq grosses des
chansons qui existent justement sur
youtube
on sait quand les chansons qui existent
ensemble qui crée une petit monde est
petit ce faire
[Musique]
cet album a été enregistré à montréal
new york et même au japon
même au japon que c'est cette passe au
japon ont fait un field recordings
quand je pense j'avais enregistré des
forêts avec les siècles super
intéressant des séquelles qui fait les
deux suspects sont bizarres vivant aussi
au japon dont les forêts les hadîths ted
est certes un truc que j'avais
enregistrée qui sont partis d'eux le
monde de l'album
[Musique]
vous êtes arrivé à montréal en 1998 vous
avez étudié à l'université concordia en
électroacoustique
vous avez vraiment faire partie du tout
début du son de montréal est-ce qu'il ya
encore une certaine magie à montréal
pour les créateurs de musique c'est sur
wii caucus à montréal puis balade aux
fins de temps je vois quelque chose de
magique caucus de l'ailé mélange des
cultures ici l'histoire est ce que je
suis l'environnement et le fait que
c'est une île c'est ce qu'un petit monde
ici les quelque chose de vraiment
spécial ici lorsque quelqu'un vous
demande comment ses partisans qui file
qu'est ce que vous répondez
maintenant c'est comme se creuse entre
une benne des mariages et une famille en
fait c est aussi comme bimbo en fait on
a travaillé ensemble comme comme des
travailleurs par quinze ans à peu près
ne peut plus chanter aimer aussi on est
en études et a mis en gras c'est une
problème j'ai une expérience à et
bizarre mais met 1
vraiment chanceux d'être d'être capables
de travailler ensemble d'accords kelly
le moment aucune parures qui disons le
plus ou qu'on connaît le moins peut-être
première fois qu'on a rencontré des
bruits à new york 16 et la venue de
notre backstage vers le parquet l'a dit
à la tv
[Musique]
et par les autres sites web et on va
connaître que les flics et là alors
c'était une grande surprise et c'est une
bronchite
après ça on dit parfois que toute bonne
chose a une fin pensez vous qu'un jour
arcade fire va avoir une fin c'est sûr
pour moi la musique rock c'est super
difficile de continuer à faire la
musique rock 70 ans drugs in the wall ça
c'est spécial mais ça c'est unique mais
tout le monde peut pas être comme ça je
prince pense qu'il faut avoir une fin
naturelle
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il va y avoir un proche à
l'album de banque et paris on pense que
oui mais il faut faire l'album avant
qu'on peut dire qu'elle va voir
oui c'est beaucoup c'est à dire merci
il
[Musique]